[Musik]
robert kratky an beide offiziere das
erste mal für dich ja allerdings ja das
erste mal aber schön was verschlägt dich
daher was hast du jetzt mit dem
bundesheer zu tun hatte ich nämlich an
der bar man jetzt gesehen im bundesheer
outfit riediger das bundesheer das
bundesheer war so nett mir die ehre zu
geben dass ich die verschiedenen
waffengattungen aber auch die
verschiedene möglichkeiten das
österreichische bundesheer in österreich
bietet gerade für junge menschen die
vielleicht auf der suche sind nach einem
nach einem entsprechenden weg ein
entsprechender ausbildung bisher
vorzustellen die verschiedenen
waffengattungen vorzustellen und auch
anrufers zu erleben und deswegen war ich
diesem jahr jetzt erstmalig eingeladen
und designer dann bin ich gerne gefolgt
ich habe auch gesehen du bist unheimlich
sportlich nein es ist allem aber ist es
ein interessanter effekt wer alle um
mich herum sind unheimlich sportlich und
da fällt es da nicht so auch wenn du
nicht so sportlich ist die ziehen die
mit quasi einmal zurück zu deiner jugend
warst du da auch mein bundeswehr
abschluss in material 2 in salzburg
irgendwie und acht monate bedient dann
am schluss presseabteilung in wien dann
am ende noch
siam preisgibt rotationen pro der
pensionen preis für geistige
landesverteidigung david streber sagen
nein ich habe das damals extrem animiert
ivan urban und nebenbei berufstätig
freiberuflich das heißt er habe
natürlich irgendwie sowohl meinen
präsenzdienst leisten müssten als auch
auf der anderen seite für
lebensunterhalt irgendwie sorgen da es
war schwierig also auch für freiberufler
mal muss man sich etwas einfallen lassen
habe
aber es animierte schon in diesem
wettbewerb auch sich zu verbessern
einzutreten und und deswegen deswegen
sehe ich das heute eigentlich haben wir
es etwas an der zeit das alte zeit ist
natürlich auch wenn man sagt 100 jahre
republik heute ein ganz besonderer fall
der offiziere dein erster für der
überblick natürlich 100 jahre
da kann man auch schon stolz auf unsere
zurückblicken ich glaube ich könnte
meinen job machen wenn eine stolz auf
österreich wäre ich halte sehr mit der
inoffiziellen hymne unseres landes von
rainhard fendrich es ist nicht alles
auch in diesem falle gold was glänzt
aber ich glaube für mich persönlich und
das habe jetzt auf 44 jahre ausprobieren
dürfen gibt wahrscheinlich kein schön
und das land dem aufwachen kann
es ist mal
eine ehre auch dieses dieses land ein
bisher beim beim aufwachen zu begleiten
oder beim aufbau zu helfen
ich glaube man könnte meinen job nicht
machen wenn man nicht auf das auf das
land und auf die menschen stolz während
der mann in dem er lebt robert kratky im
privaten sich heute auch auf der
tanzfläche
jetzt wirds schwierig meine meine
freundin ist der festen überzeugung sie
würde mir heute abend walzer beibringen
beibringen
weil ehrlicherweise ich tanze keine
schritte ihr habt gerade bemerkt es ist
so viel los auf der tanzfläche es reicht
sich zu drehen irgendwie elegant und
dabei so zu tun als wäre nichts los dann
achtet niemand auf die füße dann wirds
mal funktionieren meist so ähnlich wie
beim bundesheer ist gesagt dass wenn
alle rund um die sportlich sich aus
sportlicher wenn alle runden distanzen
sieht niemand dass das noch nicht ganz
genau
ich wünsche dir eine wunderbare bei nach
innen tages
[Musik]
[Applaus]